I'm Constanza Romero and I'm here
representing my late husband August
Wilson he did the film adaptation for
fences and he also wrote the original
play fences which played on Broadway in
1984 in 85 and also in 2010 with Denzel
Washington
tell us about from your observation what
did you see in his work ethic and how he
would dive into a story how did he
really create a world on the page
well his work ethic was this to live was
to work and to work was to live he was
always working he always was developing
his characters if we sat down to work if
he we sat down to eat he was talking
about his work and you know his
characters were were like almost real
you know he would tell me what a
character was doing and I said oh my god
he robbed a bank you know so how he
developed it he he wrote in in longhand
and then he would transfer it to the
computer and then he would always talk
in his rhythm and until it sounded good
in his ear he didn't finalize it yet
because he was all about his his poetry
was like music and if it didn't sound
right to his ear he rewrote it and
rewrote it so and and that's where you
can see that he was a poet first what
can you share with our viewers about
being so close to someone that's so
involved in the creative process and how
in some sense you're sharing your life
with another entity and that is their
work and how is that well I'm a costume
designer so we collaborated on a lot of
I would be sort of his visual dramaturg
so to speak because I would find
different photos that were inspirational
to him while they were inspirational to
me too because I was doing the costumes
and he would also say the lines out loud
and I would read his first script and
you know I would say well this you know
what about this character could she be
this or could she be that and so the
collaboration process was really
incredible but sometimes it was a little
too much we would be you know as I said
down you know downstairs eating and he
would go on and on and on and on about
the play and I would just say oh I've
got to go to work and then he'd follow
me up the stairs and eat a sandwich
right by my drawing table but you know
it was it's it's all just good memories
any of the characters or one specific
character offenses that was most like
him in some sense you know I think I
have to say that all of the characters
are him and although the character of
Rose is definitely inspired by his
mother but I don't think I think that
that is the amazing breadth of his work
is that all his characters had little
parts of himself but they were also so
imaginatively
created so I can't say that there's one
person for example when he was a young
man he was like the older son you know
who who's art nobody understood you know
because he was writing poetry on nap
and menus so like you know the younger
son
nothing younger son but the older son
Lyons he he was sort of like him you
know carrying around carrying around
that that that you know his pen and
paper like he carries around his
instrument and playing at night but
nobody in his family understanding why
the heck you know they don't get a job
yeah yes and lastly what can you tell
someone about what it's like to share
your life with someone who at some
points maybe they're critical of their
own work and watching them go through
days that maybe they didn't feel good
about their projects even though others
related to them but it was just a tough
process because they were so close to
the material and couldn't see it for
what it was yeah August hated to cut you
know if somebody said the oh the play is
longer than three hours what are we
going to do so I think that nobody would
be so stubborn and nobody could make him
cut something and then finally one of
the producers you know set me aside and
said can you tell him that seven guitars
is a little too long and actually I sat
down and I could I could really see
where it could be snipped here and there
and I was able to help him do that
but I think that I was one of the only
people he really trusted to tell him the
truth as you sing you know and and yeah
not every day was inspired not every day
was was you know a joy because creating
something is not always a joyful process
you know it has a lot of raw emotions
you know and you're practically weaving
gold you know but it's the raw material
is not all
is that you know the gold that it
becomes later beautiful thank you